what advice would you give to people who
are not always on uh hobbyists
how to get better like people are
already there I don't know purple Bells
Brown Bells Blackwells they're just like
doing like a couple times a week or
something like that like how to get
better
I think uh being consistent like find a
schedule that you can consistently train
maybe it's like you know three four
times a week or even a little bit less
just be consistent over the over the
years I think too too often people are
like oh I want to get really good really
fast and it's like definitely takes a
long time to get to where you want to be
what about the what you're doing during
like while being consistent what kind of
stuff you're working on
so honestly I think one big thing uh for
me which is something I actually started
doing once once B team was formed was uh
filming all of your rounds and then
watching it every day because you can
see what specific problems you're having
and then you can base your positional
rounds around those problems
that's really interesting it's kind of
depressing though yeah like sometimes I
have to you know I edited this podcast
for a long time I still do in part and I
hate the sound of my voice and like what
I look like and stuff but it does make
you better
yeah and I also hate the sound of
Craig's voice
this would be doubly difficult
um but I'm glad glad the rest of you are
here I don't know
what do you watch competition footage of
yourself
um like to analyze like you see yeah my
confidence that's [__] good while
you're doing curls yeah I still watching
to face my confidence
is there advice to kirgo would give for
hobbyists to get better I mean just uh
not every round has to be a fight to the
death you know I feel like you're going
to get injured you're burnt out that way
you're not going to learn as much it's
tough I would say just as a black belt
who took just very seriously for a very
long time
basically when you become a hobbyist
your skill is basically slipping your
age and your skill
and so not taking stuff seriously is
actually its own psychological skill of
like you
that it's tough it's tough like it's
tough in a way that uh is different when
you're like a blue belt or something
that you're if you work hard and you
train correctly you're going to get much
better
here you're kind of are you looking
downhill you're clicking downhill and
you're like
yeah I guess I'm gonna enjoy the art of
it reframe the victory you know like if
it's a young upcoming guy and he comes
to me you're like well that's a moral
Victory you know yeah but then that that
has to happen you have to be able to not
do that to avoid the injury sometimes
like if you want so yeah it's a
different it's a different thing plus
plus with me just
because some people recognize me they
come you have that probably you guys
definitely obviously have that I've
solved that problem how did you solve
that problem travel around you do a
salmon or anything like that yeah it's
believable that you could get submitted
once yeah but if they catch you give
them a few yeah
if people tell their friends they
submitted me to seminar yeah one time
believable yeah they got me four or five
times yeah you've robbed them of that
okay that's pretty funny but it's also
they have this energy
like they think you know they're coming
in hot and I I usually like to uh just
basically get submitted quickly twice
and just it changes everything it makes
it more fun I've noticed let them submit
you twice yeah just like very quickly
like what are the options
hold off
but then it's like it's very hard to
like yeah if you're a very serious
competitor and so I need to take it
seriously then yes but
like then people go people what they try
to do this probably is what happens to
you guys they try to impress you by
going super hard I I have people every
day come to my gym try to take me out
yeah you gotta I just stay sharp come to
practice Let's Get It On
uh do you do you feel that energy I feel
like I need to talk to Craig here first
look at a seminar like somebody's coming
in like really hard like a brown belt
will come in like and they really want
to impress you with like their technical
side of their big fan they've been
watching your DVDs like what do you do
with a guy like I make a complete joke
out of the row you know give them the
pass mess with them do stupid [__] you
know like rub them of the realness of it
because it's stupid I'm Not Gonna Roll
hard with strangers you know I feel like
you should roll with a circle of people
you trust
injuries
happen rolling hard with strangers
because that's the same way you get
injured in competition because you don't
have that uh relationship with them and
I should also mention that's probably
not a good way to impress somebody's but
just going ape [__] going 100 oh yeah
that's not at all I think the the beauty
of Jesus is like the camaraderie of it
like as you get to know each other
there's a technical like different ideas
you have and all that